[Aplausos]
estamos prontos para o court
corria tudo bem
o investimento foi o feito um parto
prefeito estava tudo bem até aos três
anos de idade
os três anos de idade eu dou a volta e
aí começaram os problemas
isto foi o começou a aparecer na vida de
meus pais e depois qual o nosso espanto
aparece um título deste texto está o que
aconteceu
além disso um dia no colégio onde
estudava em um colégio que tinha ensino
vai evitar que os pais não viviam não
era dessa cidade tinha que na altura não
havia em cima o tempo inteiro
eu era um aluno era dos alunos
referência do colégio pelo comportamento
é e tinha uma colega que chama de ana
marcela não se chamava ana que era
apaixonada por mim
vejam só a minha sorte é fantástico mas
agora muita falha incrivelmente foi
aquela era e sabem qual é o meu herói na
altura o tom sawyer
ea minha alcunha era thomas só é também
porque o que tínhamos em comum
eu tinha sargas em o cabelo encaracolado
tinha uma mala igual a mala no canal
bell é pastor lhe garante uma mala que
não fez um instinto meu pai comprou na
primeira classe e o cavalo o ensino
superior com aquela mala cavalo bola não
tome só é lembrado e é essa é essa
situação que eu tinha com ela era é de é
para a extrema criatividade era
altamente criativos eu era altamente
criativo e eu também
e com essa criatividade nessa mesma mala
e um dia por lá os artefactos os pais
pensavam que era só um caderno onde
colocava lá dentro mas não no colégio é
extraordinário ainda hoje é é
extraordinário nesse colégio que tem uma
ilha
foi aí que eu comecei a gostar vias é
por isso que tocar é ter uma idéia como
coqueiro e com os marcos está errado e
eu no intervalo às 11 da manhã disse ela
e vamos dar uma volta 49 pensava ela e
meu time um pouquinho aí vai o combina
taobao chegarmos aí o que eu fiz
dei um beijo e ela ficou apaixonado mas
quer que eu fizesse rir de bola balão e
ela ficou parada e o que eu tinha na
mala vocês não vão descobrir pesados
luta consegue descobrir
acho que não vamos ter uma corda uma
mordaça e uma certa elas alimentar é não
é assim tão mau
não era assim tão mal o que aconteceu
pois o amor raça é até ao cairo
deixei uma sozinha e fui para a sala de
aula em casa como se nada tivesse
acontecido
fui ao mais alto nível tranquilo na
minha vida como é óbvio a final e fui o
que é que eu vejo quando faltavam minas
sala
alguns condomínios e ouvir o que se
passava encontraram-na em pânico chorosa
não é o que é que aconteceu três dias
depois vão para casa suspensão três dias
pelos forcados e não desconto mais
porque senão vocês começavam o diário
não quer choque e não é preciso que o
gasto e tocar para costa em mim para que
não usa ele e este não era eu mas era
mais ou menos assim deste estilo era que
os minutos passavam uma aula inteira é
mais cavalos papel e mandava pra cima de
professor dos colegas e bia aos
professores para pôr na rua
o estado o meu estado é grave porque
você via que não queria lá estar e foi
isso e foi isso que me trouxe até aqui
e é esta a mensagem que nos quer bem
eu sabia perfeitamente que o que não
queria eu não queria estar preso numa
cadeira durante uma hora e meia houve um
professor
o grande centro minutos houve um
professor não conseguir eu sou um
indivíduo hiperativo com muito orgulho e
isso o indivíduo de terreno experiencial
eu para perceber uma coisa que também
por a mão na massa
o obstáculo não é pra mim eles tratavam
eu chegava a casa e perguntavam os meus
pais mãe porque eu tenho que saber sua
força e ritmo bateu na mãe deu
o tanque será isso mas por que eu tenho
que saber a imposição talvez lá no nome
da matemática
eu não sabia porque ninguém me
explicavam o porquê essa situação e por
isso não estava mal estar e ver o que
aconteceu aconteceu o que se previa
este menino de 11 anos é de chuva no
oitavo e simonon e até fui quase expulso
do coeduc seu foi confiar assim de ser
cumprido a página ou então buscar mais
porque a minha mãe a quarta feira uma
mulher de grande coragem e eu estou aqui
vivo também aos pais que que tenham
ainda hoje e assim vi os pais
professores
hoje em dia infelizmente andam caso
costas voltadas não fosse os professores
que eu tive que acreditaram sempre em
mim eu não estaria aqui e não acreditar
nos meus pais até a última
nessa altura foi muito árduo pois meus
pais e eu tenho que honrar porque
estiveram com por trabalhar no decorrer
da banda trabalhando eo baresi é papo
não vou fazer o trabalho mais forçado
eu tinha uma maleta e pesa mais do que
eu a marcar as pedras e chegava a casa
com um pé e estava na casa com o carro
nas mãos mas o ensinamento já se havia
outra coisa que não criei a segunda
coisa que eu não queria era o que eu
queria eo seu o juro é uma escola de
valores e aqui eu comecei a me encontrar
com uma pessoa porque é uma escola de
competência e de valor e aquelas como
ter certeza que nós vamos compreendendo
ajuda hoje o uso da minha vida
depois é para ser uma coisa que se chama
ensino profissional é o patinho foi o
ensino mas ele salvou
é fantástico obrigado ensino
profissional porque ela tinha um curso
estão ligado ao desporto
aqui um com outros olhos e assim é
palmas para aí eu já saí porque é que os
para eu até cruel até saltar até fazemos
projetos eu fiz um projeto no ginásio e
tudo que eu tinha tipo lineares machucar
holly não sei que o o desporto não
espanta o mário começa a tirar boas
notas e já não há taxas em casa os pais
anamar isto é roubar a vaga do grupo vai
durar pouco
meus amigos durou até o dia de hoje o
marido acabaram por morrer porque
romário estava altamente motivado e é
aqui que eu vos quero focar o foco é
esse é motivação se há muitos alunos
neste momento que sai em 12º ano e que
não gostam de estar na escola
vamos pensar todos com as nossas cabeças
se a culpa é deus ou se a culpa será do
sistema que ainda está implementado hoje
em dia no nosso país porque meus amigos
temos é que uma situação que depois
aconteceu comigo que foi entrada no
ensino superior e que é minha mãe dizia
assim se eu tirar o 9º anos e uma mulher
por isso agora eu estava motivado
teve uma coisa extraordinária que também
é piloto quer saber escolher os amigos e
os amigos meus charão por mim e toma
lembrar eu são todos aqui na minha
cabeça ainda hoje
e com esses amigos sejam os pais em
alguma vez este menino começou a estudar
e começou é querer entrar no ensino
superior
eu lembro perfeitamente no dia que eu
disse à minha mãe que entrei no ensino
superior ea minha irmã entrou neste
melhor mas estavam todos contentes
ele entrou no ensino superior e os
eqüinos e queimado eo marido me
perguntaram que seu vínculo
na bagagem o time praiano é legal quando
entrei
logicamente os meus pais ficaram não
serviam como estavam pública é alegria
tão grande tão grande tão grande que a
ficaram extasiados e disseram ainda vai
valer a pena
agora uma coisa não podia uma manhã
animada vexame pode gastar as fichas
todas claro obviamente já tinha gasto e
as fichas todas e fiz o ensino superior
com a nota também claro também checa mas
eu também não queria a minha mente vai
falar eu nadei está porque eu ter
acabado o curso começa em 13 permitiu
fazer muitas outras coisas e ganhar
muitas competências viajar e fiz parte
uma turma fez par com couro fugir do
canal da competição
demorava e essas coisas todas de um
tempo para tudo e mais alguma coisa no
ar em setembro a gente fala que é algo
como bailes e é época de exames de
setembro e depois ela como no futebol
fgf mística do e também sobre esportes
ainda neste dia e continua em curso e vi
que era um indivíduo que tinha muitas
lacunas a nível emocional e fui eu em
inteligência emocional na minha vida eu
sou um indivíduo com um déficit muito
grande a nível emocional ainda hoje já
estou melhor todo o percurso toda minha
linha é o contorno e o que eu fiz
fui a procurar procurar procura e
conheci esses quatro homens ao nível da
literatura
estes quatro homens que são um dos
gaúchos quatro grandes investigadores a
outros e há outras linhas de orientação
ea outras pessoas que defendem os
investigadores a nível da inteligência
emocional
eu defendo lugar na rua nos salvar e o
maia e inteligência emocional não é mais
do que nós compreendermos as nossas
as emoções saber o que elas significam
para nós e em determinada altura da
nossa vida nós sermos capazes de ir
trabalhar e disputa em si ar no
relacionamento interno e no
relacionamento com os outros
isto é inteligência emocional e é este o
percurso eu neste momento ambos é
melhorar as minhas competências no meu
relacionamento interno
segundo ele todos os dias insatisfeito é
pai tem que ter na cabeça que você
imagina
todos os dias é bater nela serão mais
vale o bangladesh um carro está com o
corpo também já fraquejam cada um seguir
sempre inventar coisas novas que o
altamente criativo
ninguém queria que vocês acham que tem
que ficar amarrado em uma cadeira um dia
inteiro olhar bom professor
estamos é matar talentos meus amigos e
foi aquilo que me tentaram fazer mas eu
tenho uma coisa você vê aqui o que não
queria
a escola do dia de hoje em portugal e
desce
quando o ator principal o professor eo
aluno tem que estar a ouvir e quieto e
calado por sinal é tão grave assim
a rua não tem muito para transmitir as
empresas hoje em dia é não há procura
dos criativos dos empreendedores e dos
contentes porque nós mandamos costas
vontade voltadas para as competências e
porque é que as contas se admitir ainda
não entraram nos programas escolares
eu tenho uns tubos foi dormir por
colegas aqui da universidade da madeira
e de outras entidades nomeadamente
honestidade mauá e coimbra que comprovam
se nós trabalhamos as condições sociais
emocionais
o montante das competências acadêmicas
em férias quando precisa que ninguém e
nós andamos todos preocupados com o
rendimento escolar
vamos acabar com isso uma vez por todas
vamos acabar com o risco
das 10 o crédito e alocou um refil fácil
perguntem às crianças o que era o grande
problema dos pais e dos professores é
que esquecem perguntar às crianças elas
querem que as crianças têm uma
consciência eu digo isso porque jamais
vou apresentar meu ano no treino com as
crianças elas têm uma consciência é
extraordinariamente incrível é
fantástica no tranquilas e perguntarmos
o que elas têm para nos dar
existem muitos um muito sul para nos dar
o que é que nós muitas vezes cortamos o
sumo e não deixamos e o nos prémios é
que eu sou um todo que ostentavam fora
para nos dar e o que é que eu proponho o
foco mais no aluno e não tanto no
professor
o professor deve ser um indivíduo que
apoia deve ser um indivíduo que está ao
pé do aluno
o aluno cria e o professor apoia o
professor não tem paraná a matéria mas
tem que saber
tem que ser um evento com isso douro do
processo para deixar todo 16 e criativo
e trabalho
dentre os objetos criados como no corpo
não tem que ter objetivos perfeitamente
vai criar os banhos definidos e tem que
ser alto o criador que é uma das coisas
que as empresas mais uma vez neste
momento patrocínio em gasto muito nas
pessoas que são autônomas e kiko criam e
nós estamos de costas voltadas com
autocriação que é um elemento chave e
extraordinariamente importante e porque
é que não será fácil
já o diário de sal caso porque percebe
aquilo que não queria depois comecei a
saber que o texto
e daí muitas marradas dei muitos
pontapés tropecei muitas vezes mas
felizmente tive sempre uma retaguarda
que o apoiou foram os meus pais e foram
os professores e os amigos que tive ao
longo do meu projeto e extraordinária e
as pessoas dizer centésimo temos ainda
bem que sou
foi minha teimosia que eu cheguei até
aqui e tenho aqui o meu projeto
o meu com outras pessoas o nosso projeto
é um projeto como esse sociais em finais
com crianças que vamos às crianças
espera é natureza tirá-las da zona de
conforto tirá las das quatro paredes
disse que a noruega foi tirada na semana
passada em três graus abaixo zero e as
crianças têm que pedir para entrar
dentro das quatro paredes
os nossos estão em cativeiro é é a que o
programa tem meninos e os emirados e os
nossos hoje em dia e em andamento os
alunos do pré escolar e do primeiro
ciclo ainda estão em cativeiro
neste momento eles veem meus vêem na rua
através da janela do carro e através da
janela da casa das crianças quase que
são proibidas de brincar e brincar
aprendiz também muito afinal quem sou eu
depois de toda esta história quem é este
militar que a vossa frente
sou indevido feliz contente e
batalhadora e sou uma daquelas pessoas
que sair o ensino entre vai mudar para
bem da nossa nação por voz e chamaram
uma nação destruída é uma só uma
potência que nunca mais acaba
e para além da nossa nação e das nossas
crianças eu estou aqui para lutar e sou
altamente provável brant só altamente
trânsito lento e com todos vós de
certeza absoluta que vamos fazer a
mudança e então fazia tudo de novo eu
fiz fazia o ensino continuar como onde e
como está até hoje eu continuarei a
fazer tudo novo hamburgo como essa temos
dia consegui chegar até aqui muita gente